new gay community organizers have
apologized for complaining to the
authorities in the u.s city of seattle
about a black pride event
charging white participants up to 50
dollars to take part
the seattle human rights commission
which advises the city council told
philip blitzen and charlotte lefevre
that the taking black pride event
doesn't violate their rights and issued
a rebuke to the pair behind a parallel
lgbt event
we would like to recommend if possible
that you educate yourself
on the harm it may cause seattle's black
indigenous and people of color
in your pursuit of a free ticket to an
event that is not
expressly meant for you and your
entertainment
the taking black pride event has stood
by its decision to charge white
participants anywhere from ten to fifty
dollars
saying it'll help keep it free of charge
for black and brown trans and queer
people
but journalist and commentator chadwick
morse says it's a prime example of
reverse racism in today's america
these sort of things are kind of a
flagrant civil rights violation but of
course
the civil rights act and everything that
came after it doesn't really apply
anymore when you're discriminating
against
white people basically which is very
funny because uh a lot of these groups
were the first to say they live in a
racist country that
white supremacy and minorities are
mistreated
uh which obviously is not the case at
all especially on any kind of systemic
level
so now we see this outright
discrimination um and it's it's
hateful it's uh ugly it's it's bizarre
and when one gay group did try to call
them out and say that this is
just racism you can't charge people
money uh based on the color of their
skin
uh now they've been forced to apologize
and uh
they've been bullied into submission by
this hateful racist organization
um it's so un-american but of course uh
that doesn't matter to these people
they hate america they want to see the
country destroyed and burned to the
ground
and remade in what image we don't know
you